Filmmakers love to throw all kinds of extra
treats into their movies for eagle-eyed fans.
Nicknamed "Easter eggs" because they're just
barely hidden and fun to find, these inside
jokes, visual gags, and pop culture references
add another level of enjoyment to the viewing
experience.
Viewers and fans discover most of them right
away, but others are a little too well-hidden.
Take these Easter eggs, for example: years
went by before anybody noticed them.
The Topless Woman In The Rescuers
In this 1977 animated Disney movie, the titular
mice Bernard and Bianca take flight on the
back of a bird.
As they zoom past buildings, a still image
of a naked woman appears in a window in two
different, non-consecutive frames.
Nobody noticed the fraction of a second’s
worth of nudity — placed by a troublemaker
in a post-production house — during the
theatrical release, and a different print
was used when The Rescuers was first released
on VHS.
When the movie was re-released on tape in
1999, better VHS players and their pausing
capabilities led to the Easter egg’s discovery.
The news spread, and Disney recalled three
million videos.
Frisky Wizards In Harry Potter And The Prisoner
Of Azkaban
The end credits of the third Harry Potter
movie involve the Marauder's Map detailing
the comings and goings of all Hogwart's personnel
in the form of footprints.
Amidst all the steps going to and fro, there's
a brief bit in the corner depicting two pairs
of footprints very close together—and facing
each other.
Yep: Those were a couple of teenage wizards
makin' some real magic with each other.
It wasn’t noticed until 2011, seven years
after the film's theatrical release.
Waldo In Apocalypto
Mel Gibson's directorial follow-up to The
Passion of the Christ was 2006's Apocalypto,
a violent drama about the fall of the Mayan
empire.
One of the most striking and haunting images
of the film is a mass grave of fallen Mayans.
For some reason, Gibson inserted a single
frame of an actor dressed as Waldo.
As in “Where’s Waldo.”
The Easter egg was only present in the theatrical
release of the movie and not the home video
version, which meant this bizarre extra wasn't
discovered until bootlegs of the original
cut surfaced.
Jack Skellington In Beetlejuice
In Tim Burton's Beetlejuice, there's a scene
in which the ghost with the most rises out
of the town model, his head spinning.
Pay attention, and you'll see a creepy little
skull on the top of his head.
We obviously had no way of knowing at the
time, but that skull was the prototype for
Jack Skellington, the main character in Tim
Burton's stop-motion animated movie The Nightmare
Before Christmas, released five years after
Beetlejuice.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
Easter eggs you’ve spotted...that no one
else has.